and you know who who the
the person in charge of the of these uh
his little private military or private
um you wouldn't call it a private mill
their their private security company
was a guy that was a retired secret
service agent
he's all over his name's kevin billings
if you punch in kevin billings
he's all over he right now he runs a
security company
he's a security consultant um
another guy named joe robinson who used
to work for buddy
this billing this billings guy what's
his name kevin kevin billings he also
he ran he wronged and ran on a security
company
companies yeah so these guys are running
the company he's also one of the guys
that gets ki
that gets arrested in the congo remember
remember the guys
eventually what happens is amadeo start
he decides look
he's got enough he starts with hold
here's what happens in order to
in order to fund this insane plan for
world domination he's trying to buy
planes and do all these things
like i said the planes are like 60
million right so 60 million
purchase so he's looking at planes he's
he's negotiating with the cypriots
to keep the planes there he's already
got russians
you can't buy an f-14 or an f-15
um fully armed they basically call them
declawing it they strip all the guts out
of it right so you can't buy it with
missiles or even the missile equipment
but if you fly it over draw the bird but
if you fly it over to
cyprus they can rebuild it the russians
will come in or ukrainians will come in
and they'll re-put everything back in
for you now i got
fully functional so that's what he's
trying to do and he's negotiating with
the site
with the cypriots but he needs money you
can't just take over the world
not that i think it's i know it's it's
insane not that i think it's true that
you could do it but he thinks you can do
it
even the cia guy was like you can't take
over the world it would take
generations to be able to pull it off
he's like but
he was i mean he the cia guy said i've
never seen someone
as capable and functioning uh high
functioning as amadeo that believed it
was possible
so what happens is he's trying to buy
the planes he's trying to do all these
things he's negotiating but you need
money to do that right he's got a ton of
companies but one of the ways he
he figures out how do i get the money to
buy all the to do all this stuff
well here's what happens is you
understand payroll let's say your
paycheck is going to be a thousand
dollars this week
okay so the company is going to send
you're going to get a thousand dollars
they're going to withhold 200
right for the irs so who
who sends that money to the ir 1000 and
probably more like 500.
let's say let's say it's 300 so you're
supposed to get
so that means the company keeps 300
bucks right right they keep 300 from me
300 from you 300
all he's got 40 000 employees paying 300
bucks that's supposed to go to the irs
what does he do he stops sending it to
the irs
and that's why it slowly grows and grows
until it's almost 200 million dollars
and he's using the money
to back to buy planes to buy all kinds
of stuff
wow he's doing just good stuff right and
here's the thing
okay here's how you how you do that by
the way which is legal
i have a company all i have to do is
report to the irs hey
irs we owe you 120 000
this week we have the money but we're
not sending it to you right now we're
holding it because we're having
we're considering going into bankruptcy
or we're going into bankruptcy
and you're just a debtor so i can't i'm
not holding the money we don't have the
money to send you but we do owe it to
you
just like if you're of any vendor that i
owe money i
bought a bunch of equipment we're making
payments to you guess what we can't make
the payment this month but we know we
owe it to you and you may be included in
our bankruptcy right
you can't come get your [ __ ] right the
irs can't do anything they go okay well
just keep keep us posted
yeah and so he negotiates with him
eventually a lot of the companies
he might owe a million two million
dollars he goes into the irs
under the bankruptcy and says look we're
gonna bankrupt it and you're gonna get
virtually nothing or let us get on a
payment plan
except less than the million or two
million we owe you except
300 000 and we'll pay you off over the
next year and they go
all right i mean is that or nothing so
they take it so he's doing this
actively doing this for years to the
tune of 200 million
he eventually ends up he eventually ends
up
buying i'm sorry backing a political
candidate to
run for president of the congo the the
democratic republic of the congo
why well because the congo has
is the law is has the largest
um i don't want to say surplus but it
has the
largest depository of minerals in the
world
zinc everything it's got all all
you know zinc um what is the other uh
you've got diamonds you've got gold
you've got silver you've got you've got
platinum but it's also got you know
there's there's a metal that's in cell
phones
that's huge okay titan whatever it is
i don't know what it is the point is
they've got tons of dub in my neck
here's the issue is that because there's
these warring factions
nobody can go in and get to it they've
been at war for
40 50 years right nobody can go so
you're either going to go in and wipe
out the entire population and then just
take it which nobody's going to let you
do
or you hope that eventually the
government gets a stable government
that's not corrupt
so he backs a political candidate that's
actually really almost an american
okay it's a congolese that came here was
educated here became a doctor
and then goes back there and he goes in
and he says look i'm going to run your
campaign
i'll fund your campaign i'm going to
provide security for your campaign
but once you're president you have to
adopt capital genesis which is my idea
of how we're going to we're going to
structure the entire economy and he
knows it very quickly
the economy will you know it'll it'll
stabilize and then he'll be able to go
into other countries
he also plans on building the largest
military in history
he's already got he's already
negotiating he at this point he was
negotiating with the um the world bank
no not the world bank
with the uh is that so what was his plan
to do this with with
every country in the world well his plan
was to go into africa
and then spread into you know whatever
nigeria and all these
neighboring eventually he ends up with
he ends up with the whole country
so you've got a continent now we're a
continent now we're moving
right he's got the president of every
country in his pocket it may not even be
the president he may just come in the
fact is once he
goes into congo he's he's got a security
force he's going to start training these
guys and build his own
private military and just take over the
rest of the country and just take over
right well why wouldn't i just not that
yeah the whole continent not the
countries
the whole continent that's what i meant
the continent yeah it's not hard to take
over one of these companies a guy named
simon mann who actually there were
actually
uh he simon mann brought had a a small
security company
that came in and actually i think with
sierra leone
there was a rebel uprising or something
where they basically were had pulled off
like a coup and they'd
forget exactly but basically they'd take
it over the country and
he came in and with his hundred and some
odd guys
takes the whole country back like they
had taken the oil fields and everything
he comes in
there's a whole documentary on it that's
what they thought
amadeo was they thought he was a simon
man that was an issue for them because
it was like a year earlier that it
happened when he goes into congo
so what happens is while his guys are in
the congo running this guy's campaign
that by the way
the guy's name is a was it
was it a i forget his name damn it
anyway
so his candidate goes from number like
30 down to number three
the other candidates that are running is
the current president and then
the the second person in the polls
was a general by the name of bimba
and uh bimba is a general so imagine if
oh sorry
imagine if george if uh if schwarzkopf
was was general of the
of the military and also running for
president do you see what i mean like
you can't do that what are you doing
that's how it is there
so this guy has got his own army and the
armies aren't all like
together like you've got an army you've
got like you guys are all under me and
they're like yeah yeah we're under you
you know you keep sending us money and
feeding us and everything we're gonna
stay here and we're gonna
you know it's not it's not exactly like
you're saying go over there and they're
like why would we go over there
why would we invade them i mean it's a
discussion this is a
this isn't this isn't like it is in the
united states right
so he was running for president they
realized that
this candidate is coming down in the
polls and he may end up winning the
presidency
so bimba ends up
grabbing all 32 of amadeo's security
staff and they grab them and arrest them
and they bring them to
a military base and they hold them for
nine days while amadeo negotiates
and the state department negotiate to
have them released
that's the whole thing the cia's
involved um
it's it's it's a whole it's a actually
there's a documentary
yeah nine days in the comments nine days
in the congo it's on my channel
go to my channel inside true crime matt
cox and inside true crime and you can
watch nine days in the congo
yeah it's great it is it is it's great
and you can see amadeo there's
interviews with amadeo
he's great he's like five foot four he
looks like the little caesar guy
he's amazing is he taller than you no i
think i i i think i'm about an inch
taller than him i
got him maybe maybe two inches with a
good pair of shoes with a good pair of
shoes
for sure i'm taller wow
you